Yay!
If
you can read this...
I could.
What does that mean?
Hello, bababoy.
That's what it means.
I'm back.
Welcome back!
Hello, hello, hello.
Everybody, welcome.
It's too late.
It is way... It's late.
It's too late for me, guys.
I love Holocure.
Did you find your try of time?
Try of time.
If you can read this, you're capable of reading.
I mean...
Hey, wisp sitting next to me.
Read that for me.
Oh, I understand now.
Thank you.
Can you minto cure me with minto beam?
You're sick?
No, Kevin!
Don't be sick.
Minto, minto, beam!
The Holocure addiction is terminal.
Yeah, it kind of is.
How is Butaro?
Have you made him and Pies a love box yet?
Got an S rank.
I'm so sad.
I thought they would be really good friends.
It's been the most pathetic thing.
So, Butaro is good.
He's been recovering well.
He's been a little drowsy because of the pain medicine from his surgery.
But, I got good news today.
From the vet, they called me.
And they were like...
We wanted to let you know that we got the...
They did a biopsy of the mass that was on his leg.
And they were worried that maybe it was a cancerous thing.
That it also spread to other parts of his little body.
But, they said that no.
It was just completely located just in that one location.
So, it should never grow back.
And this should be...
They should have taken care of it.
Yeah, they were like...
If it's something else...
They were telling me...
Some people go through radiation.
Some people go through surgery every time it grows back.
Some people even get their pet's leg amputated.
But, for my little guy, he didn't need any of that.
They were like...
It was just all right in that area.
He's a tough cookie, my little guy.
He's so sweet.
Well, not really recently.
He's been in the little donut cone for like two months now.
Poor guy.
He hasn't slept normally in so long.
And he's just been really drowsy from the medicine.
He actually has been a bad boy.
But that's okay.
I still love him.
He's excusably pissy.
Yeah, exactly.
But the saddest thing is, he tries to go to pause.
Because he's just like...
Please, I can't lick myself.
Please, just lick me.
Please, lick me.
Please.
Also, please don't clip that out of context.
He's just like me.
What did I walk into?
What?
He'll like go up to pause and just be like my cat.
And be like, please lick me.
I'm so dirty.
I just want to be clean.
And she'll like look at him and sniff him and then walk away.
And it's just so sad.
I'm like...
He gets rejected every time.
And I thought they would be best buddies by now.
But they never get into like a cat...
They never cuddle or anything.
They never hang out.
They just...
Closes out clipping from real life.
What?
Thanks for the new ringtone.
No!
At least they don't fight.
They do, but it's like a play fight, you know?
Like they chase each other around.
They like to fight more than they like each other, I think.
But that's okay.
My silly guys.
Lick request denied.
Yeah, I didn't go through the proper lick channels.
He didn't file the proper lick paperwork.
Poor guy is a big stinker for real right now.
I know!
I feel so bad for him.
He does that thing where if I scratch under where his...
Where...
Like the donut.
If I scratch underneath that to get places that he can't reach.
He like does a licky.
And he like...
And sometimes he'll just sit there and just lick the donut.
Like he's pretending to lick himself.
It's so sad.
Under where?
No!
Under there!
Yeah, poor guy.
AI summary says Minto is the cat with the cone of shame.
No!
Not me.
Medic, thank you!
Thanks for the refunds!
Christmas edition.
Guys, I've been trying to get through achievements in Holocure.
Slowly but surely.
Because like the games are so long, right?
Love the concert.
It was my first concert I've ever been by myself.
Thanks for being a perfect first concert.
Thanks for allowing us to be your first concert!
Green!
Thank you!
Thank you.
Minto, Miku is coming to Fortnite next year, January.
And this month Mariah Carey.
And tomorrow is something evil that should burn.
What the bell is going on?
Wait, it's tomorrow!
Is tomorrow the Skibidi?
Are we Skibidi tomorrow?
Skibidi is out now.
Skibidi Charler?
Forgot to mention this the other day, but literally after the first day of the con, Minto merch already started getting sold out.
By the third day, almost all the Minto stuff other than prints were out.
Seriously?
They must have not brought so much stock.
Probably.
Stinky stream.
No!
Not stinky stream.
Can confirm, I bought most of it.
LOL
Freak Phantom is in demand.
Any 300k endurance streams?
No, I don't think so.
Oh gosh, that reminds me, I have to work on stuff.
Let me write it down.
Let me write on my notepad.
We are about 1k away.
From 300k.
Isn't that crazy?
Maybe I should have a little thingy up.
Hold on.
I'm gonna do some promotion.
I was hoping they would sing this song at the concert.
But getting Parade...
Is still good too.
I don't know.
Oshispark tweets my concert pics soon.
Did you send them to them?
Work, ghost girl, work!
Wait, how do I find the...
Oh, here, hold on.
The channel's subscriber count?
Wait, how do I find the live subscriber count?
Oh, is it under this?
Oh, I see, I got it, I got it, I got it.
Okay, hold on.
One second.
Now you guys can make this number go up or down.
That's the really funny thing.
We can have this number go any way we want.
Does that cover?
Okay, no.
Go down, go down.
Actually, what if I cover it?
You guys will know.
Get it to 250.
Gary, thank you so much for the pink.
Funny you mentioned that.
Yesterday, me and my friends saw the Skibidi announcement post.
Oh, it went down!
I was so doubtful that it was real, I made a bet that if it actually got added, I'd watch episodes 1 through 69 of Skibidi Toilet.
Surely, they can't be that long, right?
Surely, it can't be that long.
I feel.
I think.
Oh my god!
It's going down!
Most of them are like 30 seconds.
Yeah, I think you'll be safe.
But you'll know the lore.
You'll know the... Oh my god!
Skibidi watch along... Hey, hey, hey.
That's Gary.
That's all on Gary.
Don't bet if you're not... You know, we didn't bet the Minto Stonks are crashed.
My birthday was on Monday.
Starchie, happy birthday!
Sorry for belated.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Starchie.
Happy...
It's like... This is... Some people might think that this is the stock.
The amount we have left of stock, right?
But actually, it's my dignity.
The Skibidi follows.
His brain rot is cray-cray.
For real, for real, no cap.
The only thing I know about Skibidi is that...
They took the assets not just from Gary's mod, but also...
Like, the camera guy is using old Nico Nico Douga stuff.
I thought these stonks are supposed to be mint.
The mint stonks are crashing.
Anyway, I've been trying to get achievements completed in the game.
And these two.
Defeat the boss of stage 3, hard.
Defeat the boss of stage 4, parentheses, hard.
What does... Why is there parentheses for one and not the other?
I'm confused.
Typo.
Kay goofed.
Okay.
Silly.
You'll be back.
You'll all be back.
Please come back.
There's some more I haven't gotten.
This one?
Oh my gosh, I've been trying forever.
Clear a game without moving.
I haven't gachikoid sauna yet, so...
And everybody keeps telling me to use sauna, but I kept using fauna.
Because I'm stubborn, but I think I'll have to use sauna.
I'll try.
Use fauna.
I tried!
I tried.
I yakkied my soul and shoulders out.
Oh gosh, I hope you liked our group shikishi.
I did!
Thank you!
Sorry for the bad handwriting.
Why does everybody always apologize for their handwriting?
This one, deal over 10,000 damage.
I haven't tried to get that one yet.
Because I don't really focus on big damage girlies.
Hardcore mode I haven't done yet.
Clear with your only...
Oh, this one I was gonna do earlier and ran out of time.
I keep trying to do the fail enhancements, but...
I guess I'm just too lucky.
Did the no move with Fubuki.
Yeah, I can't get these.
I'm just too lucky.
Let's see, what else have I not done?
Oh, every kind of fish.
Haven't done that.
Get to manager level 4.
I think I'm on level 3.
Clear hard stage without taking any damage from projectiles.
Congrats on releasing mint coin.
Watame will full send healing device items is how I got my no move clear.
I drove 700 miles to see the concert from Texas.
My first time out of my state.
It's also my birthday on the day of...
Horned Lizard!
Hopefully you didn't drive by yourself.
Oh my god.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday Horned Lizard.
Happy birthday.
Oh my gosh.
You can still drive 700 miles and still be in Texas.
That's wild.
Have over 500 HP in one run.
Win a worker... Oh yeah, these are all the new ones.
Get a pet.
Get no questions wrong in stage 4.
Wait, what?
Is this the casino?
Probably.
And then the tower.
I haven't done the rest.
I can show you though.
Look at how many coins... Look how many...
Wait.
You have to see how many I have.
Look!
I have 14,000 Peko chips.
Or Usa chips.
14,000!
You guys, I won the jackpot.
I did.
I've been gambling.
I still don't have enough for like anything.
These guys are expensive.
But I was on the slots...
I was on the slots like crazy.
You can AFK at the slots overnight and you have massive stocks.
You guys...
I need a pet.
How big are these massive stocks?
AFK the slots is the real strat.
Yeah, I was just on here and I was just like...
Spin, spin, spin, spin!
See?
I think I'm really good at this game.
It doesn't matter how much...
How little I win.
I still won.
No thoughts.
Just gambling.
Favorite time!
Favorite...
We're killing it!
I'm already at 15,000!
I'm at 16,000!
We'll get the jackpot.
Jackpot.
Jackpot, baby.
Jackpot!
The math achievement is referring to the hard version of stage 4.
We have to do mental math during a boss battle and get the...
Like in here.
This one.
No, the spoilers.
Oh,
Koyuki!
Wasureru beam!
Forgetty beam!
Forgetty spaghetti!
Koyuki, I'm afraid for you.
I'm afraid for you.
Maybe...
Don't show your face around here.
Just don't type in chat for a little bit, you know?
Everybody will jump you.
Who are you, Vtuber?
I'm Minky!
Koyuki did nothing wrong.
Don't come to chat tomorrow.
Jujutsu jumping!
Leave him alone!
It's fine!
Have you tried Withering Wave?
Same developer of Punishing Gray Raven.
I haven't!
Isn't that the game that people kept...
Kept nominating at the Gamer Awards?
Alrighty.
For stage 3...
I'm like, do you think I can go with Fauna?
Kiwawa.
Maybe Fauna.
I won't be able to lurk around today, but today is my birthday!
Could I possibly ask for a song?
Of course!
You pushed me to be my best self and I'm happy to celebrate it with Mint in the Woods!
GOGO!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday dear GOGO!
Happy birthday!
That's weird, I saw a light.
How did I get here?
Welcome.
The concert was an unforgettable experience for me and our girlfriend.
I'm sure many other Wizbloons too.
You and Toki rocked it.
Can't wait for the next one.
Thank you, Aura Bravin!
Our girlfriend.
Let's try Fauna.
Alright.
Oh, MILF.
Man, I love Fauna.
I had this earlier.
Let's try.
Heal potion.
Yeah, actually.
Maybe.
I have a great forgetting beam.
Search up weathering waves.
I got your back, run!
This is a say so stream!
She's already a healer.
Yeah, but we can get the instant heal.
And then she'll shoot her branches.
Right, well this counted the branches, I wonder.
I could dash though.
But I always forget to dash.
I feel like if it's healing, I won't forget it.
Nice cover.
It'll spawn one, one branch.
Oh, that's so true.
I want,
I want, I want...
If I go to Off-Kai, I want Off-Kai to have a Blackjack table that I will sit at.
And we can play Blackjack together.
If I go to Off-Kai Expo.
I realized that Off-Kai Expo might be a bad time for me.
So hopefully...
I can go.
Well, I wasn't invited or anything, but you know.
If I'm invited...
And if I can go.
Busy with events?
Yeah.
There's two important things happening.
I think Off-Kai Expo is in June, right?
Off-Kai Liars Bar, let's go.
Yeah, oh my gosh.
It's kind of like the...
At Tokyo Game Show, there was the...
I wonder if they could bring that to Off-Kai.
At Tokyo Game Show, the developers of...
What was it?
The...
Buckshot Roulette!
Buckshot Roulette, they had the actual table.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Something similar to that...
Could go.
I think.
You mean Backshot?
Backshot?
Oh, did I get it wrong?
Wait, Backshot Roulette.
Oh...
Wait, did I get it wrong?
Not again.
Buckshot.
Did I mess up?
Wait, which one?
Which one?
You
guys are making me question everything.
The B... The B-Shot Roulette.
There we go, I'll just call it that.
I'm scared.
The B-Shot Roulette.
Okay, I'm gonna dash.
Spooky music!
Look at these little guys, they're so cute.
Gosh, these guys are fast.
Oh my god, they're so fast.
Now obviously I wanna do...
How are you like this every time?
If you go to A-Sen next year, then I will go to A-Sen one last time before I retire from it.
Why are you gonna retire from it?
I really like A-Sen.
Give me my stuff.
We're gonna try for the... The build.
I can't remember what it's called.
Box up tops?
Oh, that's right!
I did... I took a...
Oh, you're right, you're right.
I took a...
This picture for the thumbnail.
I forgot about it.
In the thumbnail picture I got one of the special ones.
Membership stuff ain't working on my phone.
So here's my money.
No, faster!
Freak-a-deek phantom.
Card is good early on.
That is true.
It's like a first thing.
Okay, I'll take it.
You know what?
It's fine.
Oh my gosh, there's so many.
There's so many of them.
Oh, I was trapped by... Oh my gosh.
Trapped by...
Burger pumpkin.
Sorry, I have burger on the brain.
I'm not hungry.
I'm just thinking about burgers.
Burger.
Did they let you keep the wisp inflatable?
No!
Which is totally understandable.
lol It was supposed to be like a surprise for us actually.
Oh my goodness.
I gotta get this guy.
Raven feather might be good, right?
I actually haven't used it yet.
Because I got it only recently.
But since it's still early game, right?
lol
Also, I don't really care about the money, so...
Let's go for it.
Hey, healing guy!
Oh my gosh.
Stop healing, please.
Stop healing.
Oh gosh, you suck.
Oh no.
Okay, hold on.
Hold on, I wanna make it through this.
And then I'm gonna...
You do that.
I'm gonna bait you.
Yeah, I'm gonna bait you.
Okay, I'm just gonna...
I'm scared.
They're still coming through.
Just live.
Thanks, Naomi.
Awakened.
Oh, I need to buy... I was like, wait a second.
I was trying to remember what I needed for...
For the thing.
Okay, yes, spider.
Spider, spider.
Sputter, sputter, sputter, sputter.
Don't feel bad.
I really hope you don't feel bad.
You didn't have to donate one.
Thank you.
You didn't have to donate the gifted.
Thank you though.
Don't feel bad, seriously.
Seriously.
It was so... It was so...
Non-malicious, you guys.
What song is this?
She's forgiven for now.
Oh, it's Mythretree!
I was like, wait a second.
I'm stupid.
Nice.
I'm just gonna keep going.
Wait, what's the other thing that I need?
Spider cooking?
It's... Let me just look it up.
The bucket.
Bucket.
This is what you call willing it into existence.
And then we also need the uber sheep.
Nice.
I want probably also the...
What is it?
The idol outfit.
What just dropped?
Oh, gosh.
Actually, this is...
I think this one is good.
Especially for fun.
I can't take ubers.
I can only take lifts because uber banned me for some reason.
I don't know why.
I'm not quite sure why.
One day they were just like, I can't ride uber anymore.
I was like, okay.
Maybe it has to do...
I don't know, actually.
Maybe it has to do with me being banned from PayPal.
I don't know.
Too freaky.
Yeah, probably scared some people, right?
Of picking me up.
These guys aren't so tough.
What did you say?
Oh, hold to guarantee?
True.
But what if something good also is in the next one?
We're safe.
These bats are memos.
Nurse's horn.
Banned for haunting the driver.
Would it be... I'm gonna ask though.
Should I hold the bandage?
Or do you think that won't be any...
Bandage is also good for fun.
Hold bandage.
Hold.
And horn.
Horn, of course, is very good for fauna.
Fauna.
Fauna sweep.
Fauna is gonna lead us to victory, everybody.
Who hurt me?
How did I get take... Where did I take damage from?
From a...
Oh my god.
I don't remember what that stinky guy is.
I'm worried about getting too many items and...
Not being able to get uber shape, but...
Bandage doesn't do much.
Even though you heal.
Focus on collab.
True.
I think that's a smarter...
Decision as well.
It's okay.
Bandage, I feel, pops up so often.
Anytime I need what I need...
And what I need never happens, you know what I mean?
Eliminate items.
I don't know what I want yet though.
Or I know what I want, but I don't know...
You know what I love is...
This one.
The tears and the balls.
I want that one.
I do want that.
Rap Dog.
What's that one?
This one?
Tears are stored in the balls.
Stop.
So maybe we go for this one.
And then, I like this one.
I want to try for that.
I want to get the limiter, but I will...
Refrain.
Oh, X-Potato.
Okay, critical.
And I'm going to enchant...
Everything we get.
Everything we need, we will enchant.
Do not fret.
We will enchant, especially because it's cheap.
It's less expensive.
Don't get surrounded.
Too scary.
Minto makes our... Don't say that.
Don't say that.
Reconsider your words, please.
Reconsider...
What you are putting out on the internet.
Please.
Where did that guy come from?
I like how the hard stages...
Even have like a theme change, kind of.
I mean, obviously, this is still spooky, but like...
It's fun that it's not just the same stage, but more guys.
I think.
Yeah, music is so good.
I'm just running around.
A little shuba-shuba.
Who's coming?
Oh, these guys.
You know what?
I don't feel like dealing with them.
Oh, what did I get?
Flower!
I'm just gonna...
I'm just gonna chill in here while these guys pass.
Okay, they've passed.
They've passed, they've passed.
Do -do-do-do.
That was so close.
Literally grazed that.
I may be a Touhou player.
The ball!
Flower.
Touhou maxer.
I think Minto is closer and comfier vibes... Wait, what are you saying about me?
Between being soft and comfy like Fauna...
And gremlin and kusagaki like Minto, what do you think your friends would say about you?
I was not in stream and got a membo shippal.
I think you need to re-change your name, Lindsay.
You're not the weakest jailbird.
You're the luckiest jailbird.
I'm gonna hold...
My ball.
Sheesh!
What are these guys?
What are they doing?
Why did they... Why did they Metal Gear?
I took it.
What are they doing?
Wait, no, no, no, not yet, not yet, not yet.
Damage.
No ice.
Thank you for dash reminder.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Oh, I'm stuck.
Ducky, thanks for the five gifted.
No need to think about... Too hard about it.
Minto, I hate socks.
They make my feet itchy.
No, I love socks.
I always...
Okay, ball.
Idol song!
This is the one, right?
Hold on, let me double check.
Yes.
Oh gosh, I was stuck in the wall.
No!
Oh my god, please let me get my box.
Rap Dog is happening.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
Heal, heal, heal, heal, heal, heal, heal, heal, heal, heal.
Game fun.
Game silly.
Game good time.
I don't think I have anything that has a negative effect though.
I don't, I don't.
Eliminate?
I'm not gonna eliminate it.
Raven feather.
I don't think the... Okay, correct me if I'm wrong.
Because the raven feather effects are not in red, so I feel that does not count as a negative effect.
Right?
I think that's how it works.
Are you a Pokemon?
Because I can make you squirtle.
I love Gengar.
Yeah, red is negative, right?
So I feel like it wouldn't, it wouldn't do anything.
Gengar based.
Right?
It's so cute!
Okay, I'm just gonna...
Kusogaki plus gorilla.
Oh, I know!
It would be so good.
I'm gonna hold it.
We'll put a pin in it.
I'll think about it.
I'll consider it.
I'll consider.
Oh, this guy.
I don't remember what he does.
Like, I don't remember what the different colors are.
Oh my god, there's two of them!
Oh, I think he's making me slow and the other guy maybe hurt my attack.
Well, he's gone now, so it doesn't matter.
She's out!
Thanks for the 10 gifted!
Red buffs enemy damage.
So blue makes you slow, red buffs enemy.
Or red hurts.
Okay, okay, okay.
Hurts your attack.
Okay, okay.
Green heal.
Red attack, blue speed.
Got it, got it, got it.
I know what green did.
I don't wanna keep holding it.
I don't know.
Drop it.
Shackle only prevents coin loss, not attack debuff.
No, no, no.
Shackles are for any negative effect.
So like, for example, the gorilla paw.
You know how it boosts your attack, but weakens your critical damage.
Then it makes it so that it only boosts your attack.
The red numbers.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You can turn any Pokemon into a ghost-type Pokemon by using...
Brick evolution stone.
It's so... No!
You don't need it.
Okay!
I do!
Okay, fine.
Fine.
Oh, but I want it!
Okay, fine.
Goodbye.
They just never show up.
The Kusagaki shackles never show up for me.
So whenever I see them I'm like, oh, I have this urge to grab it.
You know what I mean?
Stop healing!
You ugly!
What do we need?
Okay.
Let's... Since we're working on these, let's enchant.
And if you guys see the...
If you guys see the tears, please let me know so that I grab it, you know?
Stop healing!
Stop it!
Okay, he's gone.
Because sometimes I get so focused on some things that I completely forget, you know?
I forget.
Idle song!
Eat.
Where is my Uber Sheep?
Uber Sheep, please!
Come to me!
Uber Sheep!
Everybody, this is what... This is a manifestation.
Manifestation works, baby!
We'll go with the horn.
Sorry.
Ball.
Update.
Credit card.
I'm chilling in here.
I'm not worried about anything until it disappears.
Oh!
Nice!
Slow!
Slow, slow!
Oh no!
Okay.
Ball!
We're balling!
What was that?
Oh gosh, there's so many things.
Enchant.
Idle song.
Did you get Uber Sheep?
Yes.
What did it cost?
Kusogaki Shackle.
True.
Size.
Nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
I'd love to see it.
What?
Oh, what?
I don't understand what they quite do there.
They just like freak out?
Freakazoid freak out?
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god.
They're coming.
Greed!
Guys, I can't accept greed today.
Oh my god.
What the hell?
This ain't looking so good, you guys.
I'm just saying.
They're all charging me.
Please!
Let's enchant.
I'm just gonna enchant it.
Oh my gosh.
I don't know why I seriously can't remember to dash, you guys.
I don't know why this is so difficult for me to remember.
I truly wish I could give you an answer.
I truly wish I could tell you...
Oh, I just... You know, I'm being silly goofy and choosing not to...
Not to do it because I'm so...
Whatever.
I just don't know.
Because new thing hard to remember?
I'm just... I'm an old dog!
It's hard for me to learn new tricks!
Oh shit.
I'm so not... I'm so in trouble.
Maybe.
Maybe not.
Maybe I'm good.
Come here.
Oh my gosh.
Please.
Oh my god.
He throws things so fast.
Okay.
We got one.
We got one down.
I don't know who it was, but... Oh, I think it was Chupa Chupa Chupa.
Oh my god.
I can't dodge these.
I'm stupid.
Toho.
Toho, save me.
Idle song max!
Silly minky tricks are for kids!
Save her, Toho.
Save me.
Save me, girl.
Really hot girl.
Save me.
Oh no.
Sorry.
X-Potato!
Okay.
I was going in for that, but good thing I didn't.
I just realized I don't have the golden hammer though.
I don't have a golden hammer.
So...
The collab is useless until... Yeah, I need level 50.
Where is my gold for these two?
Where is my gold anvil?
What the heck?
And where are my tears?
Right here.
Oh, it just happened.
Hello, deadbeat.
Excuse me.
Wait a sec.
Oh yeah, it won't let me do it.
Okay, not yet.
Yippee!
Drop some hot beats!
Yes.
Potatoes everywhere.
Nice!
Easy.
Easy mode.
Where are my tears?
I don't want to eliminate anything yet.
We might have to do like a combo, you know, towards the end.
Mint taxpayer.
Thanks, Minkerton.
Why is there a tax?
Oh, thanks for 299, you guys!
Thank you!
We're so close.
Psycho axe.
It does have the enchantment on it.
I guess I'll take it.
And money.
Give me money!
Why does it give me money at this point?
Neither of my things are full.
That's so strange.
Oh, wait, what did it just drop?
What did it just drop?
Where is it?
Oh, there.
Binoculars.
For the tears.
Thank you.
Thank you for your tears!
CEO tears, where are you?
Who do you think would outgaslight the other?
Crony or Doki?
The thing about Doki is she folds.
She folds, you know?
Gosh, why...
I like the slow stamp, but...
I think Doki would fold, yeah.
Yeah, easily Crony.
I think Crony would like, you know, Crony...
Crony would...
Can hold her own.
Doki panics too easily.
I think.
What are you guys doing?
What are you guys doing in here?
Oh...
Okay, I'm still.
Oh gosh, I'm still.
Oh gosh, I was still.
Okay.
Now you guys are walking.
Oh, nevermind.
You're just all over the place, it's fine.
I don't need to ult, I don't need to ult yet.
I'm good, I'm good for now.
Dash out?
No, I'm fine.
We're fine, we're okay.
Okay.
I was strong.
Honestly, my balls are killing it.
Stop failing!
That's right.
Yeah,
let's just do that.
Where are my CEO tears?
My balls are killing it.
Limiter?
I want it.
Wait, is there anything else that I... No, I guess there's nothing else that I need.
I love Limiter.
Wall and ball?
Wait, wall and ball?
What is that?
Oh wait, actually I don't remember.
Wall and ball is...
Wait, is that the one that just creates the...
No, I don't remember this one.
That's what I'll say to my future wife after our third kid's...
Okay, I'll reroll.
Increased damage of any character skill attacks by 33%.
The beetle?
Okay.
For some reason, I always thought the beetle was the... was the... this.
You know?
And so... Or the character skill was this.
So I was like, wait, I don't need this for Fauna.
Yeah, this for the branches.
So true.
So true!
So true, we'll beetle, we'll beetle, we'll beetle, we'll beetle.
See, that's why I don't mind playing with you guys, because you sometimes help me see different perspectives of things.
So thanks guys.
Oh, I just walked straight into that.
So thanks guys for... I appreciate it.
Bonk, bonk, bonk, bonk, bonk.
Bonk, bonk.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Who even reads skill tags?
I... What if there was... What if there... Is there like an aesthetic only run?
Aesthetic only run, please.
Just go with the axe.
I'm never getting tears at this point.
There it is.
How would that even work?
Oh my goodness.
Wait.
Oh, oh gosh.
Oh my god.
Wait, I can't remember!
I think I made it.
RGB stramp.
Rainbow plus trumpet.
Membership.
I feel like I could use a membership.
If only I had the shackles.
It would be so good.
Membership is pay to win.
I have a lot of coins, so honestly it's not bad if I take it.
Like I said, I'm not... I'm not doing this for the coins, so...
Five minutes of membership only costs 900 coins.
Oh!
And we have, what, five minutes left.
Let's do it.
I'm convinced I'm never getting CEO tears.
I'm convinced it will never happen.
Oh, what was that?
Oh, there it is.
Green girl power.
Green girl power!
I hate the balls with the Ian curse.
I hate it.
Oh my god, I hate... I hate it!
It's so annoying!
It's so... Why am I having to play... Damn!
Rocket League at the same time!
It's so bad!
Eliminate it?
I will.
And I'll feel good doing it.
Goodbye!
I felt good doing that.
I felt cathartic.
Goodbye... Ian cursed balls.
I walked right into that.
KFP are so silly.
So cute.
I swear to god.
Doriga, I swear to god.
Don't ever, don't ever, don't ever bring up Hayley Joel Osment in front of me.
I have had a rivalry with that guy for... I don't even know.
As long as I can remember.
I hate him!
I have never wanted to destroy someone more in my life than Hayley Joel Osment!
I hate him because his face is too small for his head!
And it's not natural!
And I can't stand that it's normal!
I can't... I... I... I'm not a folder, but I have videos of people that look like him and I just... I watch them to fuel my anger!
Oh my god.
Why?
It's not... I hate him!
I will never be okay with him existing.
I will one day destroy him with my own two hands!
I swear!
Oh my god.
Stop calling me Hayley Joel Osment, please!
I have had this... I've had this... I've had... I've had... I've... I've hated this man!
I'm seeing stars.
Oh my god, hold on.
I have to compose myself.
I think I'm alright.
Re-roll!
Raging some rando?
No, he's not a rando.
What are you talking about?
He's... He's unfortunately famous and I hate that for him.
He's my arch nemesis.
You know what?
I'm just gonna go with the axe.
Gosh dang it.
Everybody has like an arch nemesis and that guy is mine.
His face is not natural.
That really freaks me out and so when I see pictures of him...
It makes me really freaked out, okay guys?
Please!
Yeah!
We did it!
We're here!
Nice.
Nice, nice.
Super collab!
Yeah!
You know what?
Upgrade.
I'll wait for the other one.
Maybe we'll, you know, maybe we'll get...
Oh shoot.
Maybe we'll get CEO tears.
Who knows?
Maybe.
You know, maybe it'll happen.
Someday.
I don't like Dash from the Incredibles for a similar reason actually.
Dagger for the axe.
Wait, what's that one?
Oh, yeah.
Let's...
We can do that and then we can...
Maybe hope for the tears later.
I understand that comparison.
It's like, oh my gosh, there was that one episode of Rick and Morty, like the tiny people or whatever.
It's the same thing.
Thank you, thank you.
Kiss.
Love and hate are two sides of the same coin.
No.
I also forgot I can upgrade this.
Wait.
Yeah.
Upgrade!
Hayley Joel Osment has all the CEO... Is it Osment?
Os-mend?
I don't know.
That's how little I ever care to think about him.
Except when I'm plotting his demise.
Oh, they're yelling at me.
Okay, enchant.
Osment.
No!
That's not it.
Guys, how are we feeling about this run, huh?
How are we feeling about this run?
Hayley Joel phantom art being made right now.
I've already seen it, unfortunately.
I literally stopped looking at my hashtags because of how much people were posting stuff.
I was like, I can't look again today.
I'll look tomorrow, maybe.
I don't know.
I'm scared.
I don't feel safe.
I feel uncomfortable.
I feel everything, every bad emotion anybody can feel about something.
Sick to my stomach, just... Oh, ouch.
Oh my God.
I didn't know which way he was charging at me.
Oh, we got him.
I've
done nothing to you but plot your demise.
I don't
wanna see his face anymore, please.
I
can't...
He must be stopped.
I don't like him.
Ninja headband.
Do I have any melee weapons?
Do my balls count as melee weapons?
I know my owl dagger and the...
Axe counts?
Okay, I'll drop it.
I feel sick to my stomach.
You gotta focus.
I gotta... Yeah, you're right.
I won't let... See, I'm telling you.
He's my arch nemesis.
He's trying to...
Oh, tears, please.
I'm okay.
I'm focused.
My head is in the game.
We're fine.
Thank you for the pink, though.
The kid that can see dead people.
Yeah, I think so.
Koiyuki, thanks for the gifted!
Alright, owl dagger.
You're a wispy... No.
No, he's not.
He's not welcome here.
He's the original of the small phase.
It's just not right.
Oh!
Isle costume!
Wait.
It's so late now, but it should be...
I wanna max dagger.
With 30 seconds.
I know!
Max dagger.
Get away from me.
Oh my goodness.
What is going on?
Okay, we're fine.
Oh my god.
We're fine.
Everything's fine.
Everything's cool.
We're chill.
Everything's fine.
Oh my god.
What in the...
I just nearly... Died for real.
I got stuck on the wall.
Where's my... Oh my god.
Please.
Two!
Wawa's coming for you.
She's so fast!
Wawa!
What?
Didn't I... Did I hear a...
A thingy?
Oh my goodness.
Sorry, Kiwawa.
A anvil?
Yeah, Ducky!
Attack up!
Oh my gosh, you guys.
We're doing it?
Gotta be a nightmare anytime you play Kingdom Hearts.
Just don't think about them.
Where is...
First try!
We did it!
That was so fast!
Phono sweep!
Yay!
Yay, yay, yay!
I was really hoping that...
I could go to a show and see Fauna perform at it, you know?
I'm so... I'm so... I'm so salty.
I didn't go to New York now.
I was just like...
I should've gone!
I had no idea!
But...
It's OK.
Maya!
Welcome to membership!
Thank you!
Phono sweep!
Double green Oshilo!
Thank you!
Yeah, I...
I went to the one at AWA, right?
But I... Oh my gosh.
And I was really excited because it was my first ever holo concert.
And I was really excited to see them actually on stage.
But I feel that...
I feel that maybe they should've considered what the stage looked like.
Or rather, they should've...
Maybe...
The stage was way too low.
It was so...
Oh my gosh.
When people were asking me, they were like, how was the concert?
I was like, it sounded great.
It sounded good because they sounded good.
I would sometimes see Kiara's hat.
Or I would sometimes see Ina's halo.
I'd be like...
And then also there were pillars.
And I also couldn't see above people's heads.
But the side screens...
I don't wanna just look at the side screens because that's basically what I watch when I'm watching them do a concert on YouTube.
I wanna see them on the stage.
And so...
I was like...
You know, I'm 100% for people standing up during a concert.
I hate when people are sitting...
And I wanna stand up and then someone gets mad at me for standing.
I hate that.
But this was the only time I've ever thought, oh my gosh.
I know I'm short and I can't see much, but...
Even floating a little bit.
But I was like, no.
I think people should've sat for it.
For that one.
Just that one.
Because...
Or, like, I think they should consider...
You know, having...
Maybe, you know, when they do the Hololive, like...
Stages in 3D.
Like, having them...
Having different versions where, like, you know...
Oh, we see what the stage is like.
We're gonna have you guys perform on the top...
Of, like, the...
Of, you know...
How do I...
Like, the steps.
Or something like that, you know?
Something like that.
We all sat down for the yapping.
No, that's just how MC works.
You sit when there's MC...
And then you stand when there's a performance.
That's, like...
So normal.
That doesn't even bother me.
But...
I couldn't even see them then!
I didn't even...
I didn't see anything!
But...
Holofest this year is having a stage in the center...
And two on the side.
Not sure how that'll work, but hopefully it will alleviate some of the problems.
Isn't that how it was last year?
Where they had, like, the different stages that you...
Like, turned around for?
I was in the second row and standing most times...
And it was even too low for me.
I heard it was a few feet lower than it should have been.
Really?
Last year had three stages.
They had screens on three sides.
Is that not what you just described?
I think I misunderstood.
But yeah, I was worried.
Because I was, like, asking people.
I was like, oh my gosh, was...
Was our concert the same way?
Because I was nervous that maybe people didn't see it much.
But from who I asked, they said that...
It was good that they could see.
But...
You know...
And I don't want to entirely blame the convention.
I think there was maybe just a miscommunication.
Because it could have been like, you know...
Obviously Hololive is going to do the same exact setup they do.
But I think they should also, you know...
Talk to the convention and be like...
Hey...
How high up is...
You know...
You can get a gauge of...
Like, I feel that maybe a lot of convention centers have the same height...
In terms of stages...
In a room.
So...
I think that...
If they talk to them and were just like...
Oh yeah...
We're gonna have a version...
Like, where the girls are able to be on steps.
And perform on the steps of the stage.
You know what I mean?
Rather than performing on the floor of the stage.
Is what I'm trying to say.
Something like that.
Because if you noticed for Phantom Thief 2...
Sometimes we would perform on the floor...
And sometimes we would move up on the steps.
And then you...
You know...
We would kind of move around.
But...
Yeah...
I think...
You know...
Just so...
Something like that doesn't happen again.
I couldn't see them that well and connect the world.
I mean...
I'm so used to not being able to see much at concerts in general.
So...
It doesn't truly bother me all that much.
But I was just like...
Oh man...
I would sometimes think that I saw them moving around...
But it was someone's pen light.
So I was like...
How...
I was like...
How tiny are they?
You know...
Like how...
How teeny tiny are they over there?
But...
You know...
It didn't stop me from...
Not having fun.
So...
Yeah!
Oh my gosh, guys.
We did it.
Hold on, I'm just gonna pick Fona again.
We did!
Hard Stage 3!
And then...
Stage 4 Hard!
Stage 4 Hard.
They said for AWA next year, they'll prep a lot more for Hololive.
They just never had them before and didn't quite know what to expect.
I can understand that too.
I can understand that.
I think the idea of big VTuber concerts being a thing is fairly new.
So I have confidence people will get better at pulling them off.
Yes, but also...
Miku concerts have been a thing for like 10 years.
And it's like the same exact thing.
It's nothing different.
So...
I'm just saying.
That maybe...
We already have the technology.
You know...
I'm just saying.
Gorillas?
Yeah, even before.
The concert inspired Pia to be an idol again.
She killed it.
She was so great.
Spray stuck.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
There goes Mint's AWA invite next year.
No, I'm just saying.
I mean...
I'm not criticizing.
Or rather, I feel like I'm giving valid criticism.
I don't feel like I'm bashing.
I'm just saying, hey.
Hey.
That's all I'm saying.
Just wanna say Oishi Spark did a great job for Phantom Thief.
All the staff were really nice.
Oh, I'm so glad.
Constructive criticism.
That they didn't ask for.
I have... I'm a VTuber.
And I must give my opinion.
I must tell you...
What to do.
No.
Unsolicited constructive criticism.
Yeah.
Anyway.
Guys, what do I need to prepare for stage 4?
I'm scared.
Do you think we can do it with Bana again?
Or do I need to do it with someone else?
Your body and soul.
I don't have a body.
I'm only soul.
I'm a ghost.
Bana is OP.
Do it with Bana.
Okay.
Minto's Stilt Fund.
And what's even worse is I didn't wear my... I usually wear like a high heel or something.
I didn't wear any.
But I don't think it would've made much of a difference.
Not gonna lie.
Do you have any upgrades left?
Nope.
I have everything.
Okay.
Moomint has a lot of damage.
My Moomint...
She's not Gachikoi though.
She's small, small.
That's why I was like Fana or...
Or Kiara.
Let's try Fana though.
I'm sad I only have 188 sessions in Ace Combat.
None.
Nah.
Honestly, I'm surprised it's not more.
Okay.
Here we go!
Why is this so sca...
Oh, there's something down here.
Tiara?
Pfft.
I guess this would be good to get early, right?
I think I've used it like...
Trying to...
I think I used it when I was trying to do the sell 10 stamps thing, so...
Great pull early.
Oh, goodness.
There's...
Lightning?
Oh my goodness.
Oh my god.
These guys are so fast.
They're so fast!
Speed penguins!
Holy cow.
Actually, CEO's tears is not bad though, so...
Might as well grab it.
Oh, what's this?
Haste!
Give me haste.
Holy cow.
Oh, it's really hard to see on this map too.
Oh my god.
It's tricky to see because of the night, you know?
Nice start.
Let's see how we go from here though.
I'm gonna increase my haste.
Haste is so...
Having good haste...
Does not waste.
Oh my god.
A good haste does not waste.
Oh, knockback.
I'll take that.
Lightning kills, beware.
Oh, thank you.
I'll try to remember to dash.
This is like the...
This is the true like...
Dash killer.
They're like, if you don't dash...
You ain't gonna make it.
What is...
Why is it glowing here?
What is this?
Oh, it's just like spotlights.
Oh, it's Metal Gear.
See?
Just like that.
Holy moly.
Oh my god.
You know what?
Actually...
That worked.
You know what?
It worked.
Not my proudest moment.
It's so hard for me to hit control.
I should just rebind it.
It's just so hard for me to hit...
Control.
I don't...
I'm just...
I think I haven't done so though.
Because I just don't know what to rebind it to.
You know what I mean?
I've been like...
I don't know what would be a good...
New key.
Oh, wow, I ran right in that.
Oh, hello.
Get more tears.
More tears.
Guys, I got a new keyboard recently.
And it's very...
I don't mind the keyboard I have now.
I only... Oh, nice.
Spider clicking.
I don't mind the keyboard that I have now.
But...
I just wanted...
I wanted one...
I wanted like a 70...
I think it's 75%...
The one that has the numpad.
How thock is it?
It's very thocky.
It's very like...
Also, the one I have now just doesn't sound very nice.
So I wanted a numpad.
It's not full size though.
With numpad is 90...
Oh, it's 96%.
It's not 100%.
Controller goes hard.
People have been telling me to do with controller, but...
I guess we increase our...
You know what?
Increase speed.
Love that.
You know what?
Yes.
Increase speed.
You know what?
Actually a win.
Otherwise, I was gonna be a little sad, but...
Yes!
More speed!
Speed, speed, speed, speed!
More funds.
I don't really need them.
I need the...
Oh my goodness.
Oops.
I ate that.
This remix?
This remix slaps.
It's so good.
What was it?
Game is really trying to kill me.
It's like that's how the game goes or something.
It's like the game is intentionally trying to kill you.
It's like that's how you play the game or something.
That'd be... It's craziness.
We ball, we ball, we ball.
I know I probably should be focusing on spider cooking, but it's fine.
Maybe.
Maybe it's fine.
Oh my gosh.
Somehow we absolutely lucked out of that.
Holy cow!
Mint to be!
Thanks for the five gifted.
Thank you.
Overshape!
Alright, now we just need lava.
Lava bucket, we're good.
Oh, take that.
I'm scared.
The boss is gonna be...
Increase speed.
Should we also try for rap dog again?
Should we also try for rap dog?
Because we have idle song right here.
Hi Mint.
Hi Sammy.
Thanks for the eight points.
Rap dog good.
Rap dog!
Not to be confused with rack dog.
Rack.
Nice.
If I die, it'll be the saddest.
It'll be absolutely...
Oh no, I can't die.
No, no, no.
There's too much pressure you guys.
There's too much pressure.
I'm scared.
No.
Don't jinx it.
Try it.
There's too much pressure.
Are these guys gonna charge me?
Nurse's horn!
Yeah, I'm gonna take it.
Anything for heal.
Heal, heal, heal, heal, heal.
No pressure.
Under pressure.
But we're fast, we're strong.
We're girl bossing.
We got balls!
More...
More balls.
I'm gonna focus on my balls, because...
I feel that...
We have the CEO tears.
But I need more anvils.
We're strong!
The anvil.
We need to enchant.
That one fell fast.
Critical.
I'm gonna go into...
Hmm.
Is she ready for maths?
No, I'm not.
I'm not ready for maths.
Swap crowbar?
Wait, really?
I love having...
Having knockback, though.
I feel like knockback is so great.
Right?
I love having knockback.
And then you get knockback from...
From this.
From the spider cooking.
Enhance haste.
Enhance.
You say one guide, but I was more than one.
Should I get a body pillow?
I'm gonna hold body pillow.
Just in case I change my mind.
Crit over knockback, but my knockback is not...
Or my crit is not so much anyway.
Could be higher.
I guess it would be higher if I use that.
But look at how good knockback is.
Oh my goodness.
Because Fauna doesn't do direct damage, knockback doesn't do much with her.
Stamps only apply to the main weapon.
You're right.
But I've been knocking them... Maybe I've been knocking them back because of other stuff, though.
It does work, just not great.
That's the spider cooking knockback.
No, I don't think it has knockback yet.
It's only level 2.
I don't think it has it, right?
I can't remember.
Idle costume!
Merry Christmas, Minto.
Merry Christmas!
For now it's OK.
Good thing we got the speed.
Good thing we are speedy.
I wish I could get some anvils up in here, please.
Spiders...
Look how slow they are.
Oh my gosh.
I dove right into it.
So messed up.
Oh my god.
Negative 6?
Are you serious?
Oh my god.
Oh god!
15?
I messed up.
Oh my god!
I don't know.
She's dead.
We did it.
I'm safe under my tree.
I don't want to use that yet.
Give me a regular anvil.
Damn it.
Give me a regular anvil!
You cheapskates!
They don't give you enough time!
Don't figure that out!
That's the only time you have to do it though, right?
Oh my gosh.
Lisa, Lisa.
I'm holding onto Lisa forever.
Maybe I switch her out with the knockback.
Oh my goodness.
What did I just...Oh, another stamp.
Oh, slow.
Slow.
There's the raven feather again.
Slow is good here.
You know what?
That's true because everything is so fast.
Everything is so fast.
Too late for feather?
We still have half the time, but...
Plate is good.
My speed though...
I don't think it would be good here.
You have to be really fast here.
Though you do reduce damage taken.
You'll need the extra lives.
I'm going with this.
I have no confidence.
Swap.
Oh, nice.
One day, I'll get an anvil.
A regular old anvil.
A regular Joe anvil.
Someday.
One day.
Maybe.
One day I'll get an anvil.
Just a regular old anvil.
One day.
Just a regular guy.
Just a guy that says, I'm just a regular anvil.
I just want to enchant my stuff, but...
At this rate, I'm feeling...
Losing confidence, because I have no collabs at all.
I'm lonely.
I have no collabs.
Lonely, lonely.
I am so lonely.
I have nobody to call my own.
Nice.
Just talk to people forehead.
Scary, scary, scary, scary.
The scariest thing you could ever suggest to me.
Oh, they got the bombs.
I feel like that was more spots than usual.
More lightning spots than usual.
Oh, a strawberry.
Oh my gosh.
I'm never gonna get an anvil at this point.
I just want...
I have nothing enchanted at all.
This sucks.
Reroll?
No, for anvil?
I think I'm...
I still have a bunch of stuff to level up, so...
Oh my goodness.
Screw it.
Oh.
Oh god, I just have to be careful when my tree goes away.
Oh my gosh, oh my gosh, oh my gosh, oh my gosh.
No, no, no, no, no.
Oh god.
Let's focus on...
Nice.
One down.
Okay, I'm gonna try to focus on...
Oh my god.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
I was trying to say Ollie.
I think I might just have to take it, you guys.
Special is OP.
Does it look like I can use my special right now?
No.
Okay, so...
Did VTuber use her ult yet?
I think if you used your eyes, you would know.
Anyway.
Check in the bottom left for when the tree despawns.
Really?
It shows that up there?
Oh my gosh, thank you.
Alright.
We're just gonna take it.
Exapotato!
Okay.
Second down, second down, second down.
Oh my gosh, Ollie, please.
Three down!
Nice, nice, nice.
We're looking good, we're looking good.
Okay, okay, okay.
Love the concert this weekend.
Thank you!
The next song was perfect.
Our road trip playlist was idle music and lonely island.
The perfect combo, huh?
Oh my goodness.
Oh my gosh.
Nice.
Okay.
Stamps all of a sudden.
Stamps, stamps, stamps.
Hold on.
Let me grab my earnings, please.
Let's grab our winnings first.
There was lava?
Oopsie.
You know what?
I was so...
One brand.
Oops.
I missed the bucket.
Oopsie.
My bad.
What is this one again?
Oh, stun enemy.
We'll just strike.
My attack.
Let's be stronger.
Strong.
Strength.
Actually...
If I up my size though...
My balls will be huge.
They'll be all over the screen.
They'll be...
They'll cover the whole screen.
Cool bar, cool bar.
Oh, it's just for main weapon.
You're right.
I wish I could get the double healing.
You know?
Okay, I'm gonna re-roll.
And I'm gonna re-roll.
I'm gonna re-roll.
Re-roll.
There it is!
I got...
Are we good?
Bucket.
You almost re-roll.
I really did.
I think...
It disconnected for a second.
Where can I...
Flower.
Whatever.
I'm strong.
Strength and...
Strength.
And myself.
Oh, no, no, no.
Oh, no.
You guys, I never...
I still haven't gotten a single anvil.
It's kind of insane.
What's up with that?
Game is rigged.
Maybe.
Against me.
It's rigged against me.
You got two super items.
It's rigged!
Boom, boom, boom.
Leave me alone!
Oh, my God.
Look at all of them.
Lava.
And we're almost to level 50, so this is perfect.
Cinderella!
Pick up my...
Spoils of war.
Pick up all my earnings.
Oh, don't charge at me.
Don't do it.
Where did you go?
Oh, goodness.
They die so easily.
See, I'm too good.
Kuwabara, Kuwabara.
If I die to the lightning...
It'll just be a Metal Gear reference, okay?
Guys, I would have totally done it on purpose.
Oh, skill.
Haki-doki!
Just in time.
Perfect.
Just in time for...
Us to hit level 50.
What just...
Wait, what's...
Oh, gold anvil.
Hello?
Excuse me.
Thank you.
I don't think we're ever getting an anvil, you guys.
So, it's just...
It's fine.
Just watched your concert, Minto.
I cried a lot.
Amazing job!
It seems like you had so much fun.
We did have so much fun!
Thank you.
Don't cry.
Why are you crying?
Oh, wait.
We're fine.
Oh, what do I do with this guy?
The size stamp.
I don't... Just sell it, I guess?
I don't need it, I suppose.
Sell it.
Save it.
What do I save it for?
Oh, I guess for like...
If I get a different stamp.
I don't know what collab I want to do next.
I love having...
Balls all over the place.
And we'll have the songs all over the place.
Then we'll... I don't know.
Have something else all over the place.
I got stuck on the...
I got stuck on the statue base!
Oh my goodness.
Scary.
You kidding me right now?
Whammy water and glow stick?
That's a good one.
You didn't get the references since you're new.
I feel like we didn't have so many references, but...
Thank you for still going, Schwartz, even though you're newer.
Thank you.
I don't think we tried to be like...
Like...
You must know...
Doki or Minto to understand this.
Is it with you and balls today?
Because I have the balls right here!
The ring of fitness!
Must be a ten year fan.
It was genuinely fun regardless.
Thank you.
Enchant.
Increase size.
Where
were you guys?
So messed up.
That's the way the cookie crumbles, everybody.
Two in a row, even.
Alright, give me my gold anvil, please.
Thank you.
Wait, I think...
And we got the hammer!
Give me my other gold anvil, please.
Give me all my...
Wait, give it to me.
Give me.
Please.
Please, onegai.
Onegai shimasu.
I'm asking so nicely.
Really?
Nope.
What?
Are you kidding?
Oh wait, it's over here?
Why another one?
Oh my gosh.
You guys...
What happened?
That was... What happened?
The headphones?
You know what?
Yeah, let's go for it.
Oh my god.
Oh gosh, that scared me.
The fan letter.
Nice.
More headphones.
How... Let's see.
Trying to figure out...
So we're doing... What was it?
Whammy water and...
What was the other...
Can't remember.
Glow stick.
Yeah.
We'll freeze these guys up, baby.
As long as I gotta get the whammy water first, but you know.
It'll come.
My luck is just that...
That stupendous.
You know.
You know, we'll get it.
I believe.
Oh goodness.
Glow stick.
In less than three minutes.
Exactly.
I think I just ate the danmaku.
Yummy.
Yummy danmaku.
Ascend here.
And I just...
Kill!
We kill.
Just hang out with them.
Yeah, exactly.
Just like, hey buddy.
Oh my gosh.
So much on the screen.
My eyes.
But now we don't have a...
We don't have our ult.
So we have to be very careful.
We don't have our ult to rely upon.
Oh, there's a stamp there.
Second stamp.
Right stamp.
Everything is maxed out.
Goodbye.
Which one is this one again?
I can't remember.
Adds one additional shot to ranged multi-shot weapons.
This is ranged.
Technic.
Does this count?
More leaves.
What do I get rid of maybe?
But my attack...
My damage is 25.
More leaves.
Okay, we'll swap.
Wait a minute, water!
I told you guys we'd get it.
With one minute left to spare.
I thought, I'm not gonna lie, I thought that was a monkey.
I'm afraid of what the boss is gonna be.
At least nobody is charging at me yet.
Nice, nice, nice.
They fall, they fall!
They all fall!
You should be afraid.
The music doesn't help at all.
It makes me feel so intense.
Makes me feel so intense.
Oh, hi Green.
Goodbye.
Oh, wait, is this max?
Oh, just kidding.
Goodbye, Green.
We have a piggy bank.
Actually, I'm making really good gold.
For all things considered.
Making pretty good gold for all things considered, right?
Alright, here it comes!
3, 2, 1!
Boss!
Oh my gosh, oh my gosh.
So far so good.
Where did she go?
Why the hell are you all the way up there?
Oh, you know what?
This is fine.
I'm chilling in here.
Oh my gosh, there she is.
Banana!
It moves, it moves, it moves, it moves, it moves, it moves.
Holy cow.
Oh gosh.
Ma'am!
Oh, bananas!
Can't believe we first tried both!
First tried both!
Yippee!
Final sweep!
Mintos Gaming.
Back down, shoutout!
Thank you for the...
I know, now I can breathe.
Holy moly.
Very thanks for the tag gifted!
Oh, where did it go?
All of them.
First try even.
Minky fought monkey.
I got the monkey.
I can't believe we did both.
First try!
Kiwawa, OP.
Fauna, OP.
Minto, OP.
Mayoshi is so good at video games.
Now what?
To the slots?
Let's take all our winnings!
And throw it to the wind!
Elfriede, thank you for the tag gifted!
Thank you!
I have a question.
I try to buy more USA chips with my money, but it won't let me.
Why not?
I hope I said your name right!
Thank you so much for the 50 gifted!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
1000 is the cap?
Why?
Why can't I...
This is not pay to win?
Is this not pay to win?
Auto-click the slots.
I do have an auto-clicker.
It's kind of fast though, because I use it for...
I use it for...
Let's see how fast can we go.
I just casually got the jackpot!
Use it for what?
Cookie clicker!
Guys?
Wait, but what about when it's time for the mini-game?
Oh, it's kind of working.
Finish!
What's happening today with Minto's luck?
My afterlife is turning around, baby!
It's all...
Minto from here!
It's all Minto from here!
Which could be either uphill or downhill.
No one can really say, huh?
It's all coming up, Minto!
Aw, dang it.
We're at 22,000.
You guys, we might be able to get a monkey today.
Thank you guys for helping me out during the...
During the...
The stages.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you guys.
Minky, Minky, Minky.
We're gonna buy a Minky.
We're gonna get a headgun Minky!
Thanks for the superchat!
Anytime, Mint.
Our pleasure.
Oh my god.
I didn't see you.
I didn't see you there.
My arch nemesis.
I wouldn't recommend the monkey.
Why not?
Does it smell?
Does it poop?
Is it terrible?
1,000!
I think that's my highest yet.
It might poop.
It actually poops?
Does it fling poop?
My mom, when she was a kid, she had a monkey.
And my grandpa got it for her.
So her dad...
My grandpa got it for her.
No wait.
That's a lie.
My grandma got it for her.
And then one day my grandpa came home and the monkey flinged poop at his face.
And he was like, get this monkey out of here!
The monkey threw the poop at his face.
I guess it doesn't really surprise anybody though that my grandma would get my mom a monkey.
So like, I don't...
I don't know how long she had it for.
Classic grandma move.
Hi!
Thanks for 80 months!
Deep monkey poop lore.
Wait, hold on.
I didn't get to read your super chat, Brian.
Crab battle.
Did that prepare her to raise you?
My mom?
I don't know.
How does your grandma even know where to source a monkey for pets?
Well, I mean, that was when my mom was a kid, so...
You know, it was a long time ago, right?
I bet you could just go down the street and find a monkey.
Probably.
There's an achievement for getting all of the math on hard level 4 right.
So there's that.
Oh no, but I want to get all the achievements in the game!
Don't let that distract you from the fact that...
Grandma Minto bought a fucking monkey.
Does it work if you pause?
I don't know.
Good question.
Your stream is like the happy toucan.
Thanks, Evan!
I love your toucan profile picture.
Jackpot!
Surge, thanks for a month!
Message field too short.
Minto cute.
You can pause, really?
You guys, how much is it for the monkey?
Is it 50,000 like the rest?
Because we're over halfway there.
K.U.
is planning on moving tower achievements so it doesn't count towards 100%.
Yeah, I remember him mentioning that he was gonna make some other achievements that don't count towards 100%.
But for everybody who wants to...
Torture themselves.
It's... What?
It's 111K!
You guys, we were at 29.
Uh...
I...
I wanna do the tower, but...
I just don't like Jump King.
I don't like Jump King even a little bit.
Cool stuff at 300K, so consider subscribing, guys.
Thank you guys for getting me to 299!
I appreciate it.
Took me 4 hours.
I know, like, I don't...
I want to read Grandma Minto's autobiography.
My sister has been, like, recording her every time...
I see her.
Did you see the girl wisp at AWA wearing a perfect wig of your hair?
It was very cute.
No!
I didn't!
Though I did see, there was one booth...
I think it was in the Artist Alley that had a Minto Dolphy.
They had a Doki Dolphy too, but...
It's crazy.
Joey, thanks for the gifted!
I saw a hotdog Minto.
I saw a hotdog Minto!
I did see that one.
So cute.
So, so cute.
I'm new.
Hi, hi.
Hi, hi!
Welcome, welcome!
Hotdog.
That's a real hotdog moment.
Consider slowing the framerate down.
It makes the tower a lot easier.
Is that the hacks?
Hotdog, I'm hungry.
There were corn dogs at the convention.
But I didn't get any.
Instead, I got tater tots.
And then, my friends made fun of me for getting tater tots.
But they were some dang good tater tots.
I was like, wow.
These are actually really tasty.
Sit in line for the concert near hotdog Minto.
She got a lot of compliments.
So happy.
I'm really glad.
I was really worried that it was gonna be super duper cold.
Because of people... And also raining.
People having to wait outside for the concert.
I was really, really nervous about that.
I was like, oh no.
Are people gonna have to either wait out in the rain?
Luckily, it rained on Sunday instead.
But I was worried people would have to wait in the rain.
Or wait in the super cold.
So I was like, whew.
It wasn't such bad weather.
The weather was really nice, thankfully, for the concert.
I'm kind of Ameonna.
Ameonna is like...
It's kind of in the name.
It's rain woman.
So, usually for events and things that I want to do, it's raining.
But...
Yeah, I'm a rain woman.
A rain bringer.
But...
There was a movie about it.
So true!
Tenki no ko.
Ame otoko here.
Yeah...
But...
Yeah, so I'm really happy.
It wasn't like that.
Rinze!
Thanks for 8 votes!
It was really cool.
We could pick up our Happis at the con so we could wear them at the concert.
Right!
I was so happy that...
Yeah, Lights was able to make that work out, honestly.
I was so like...
Jackpot!
I was so nervous about...
But they worked really hard to be able to get them in time for the concert.
So, were you happy about it?
Yeah!
Happy, happy, happy!
I'm still waiting on mine.
I believe they said that orders were going to be shipped out this week.
But also account for, you know, slow...
Slower shipping because of the holidays.
So...
Hope you were able to see my Ace Combat figure.
I did!
I saw it!
I liked your tweet!
Just peeking in.
Hi, Liquid!
They just tweeted out the boxes to be shipped.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So...
If you pre-ordered a Happy...
Which, there were so many boxes.
I did not expect so many people to order some.
I was like, wow, that's a lot of boxes.
But it was really exciting to see people wearing them.
I was like, wow, this is my own Happy.
This is my own...
My own designed Happy Coat.
I was so happy.
I was happy about the Happy.
Need to get a Happy and a good pen light for the next concert.
Yeah!
Asukusu!
Thanks for the 5 gifted!
If you want a good pen light...
Anything Lumica...
Lumica being the brand...
Is a good quality.
I really like the Lumica ones because they make them pretty easy to use.
Not just because I'm biased.
Lumica.
Lumi... with a C.
C-A.
Lumica.
People like you and want me to merge, dummy.
I still have my Love Live pen lights.
Yeah, those work too!
Yeah.
You don't have to have the pen light of the thing you're watching.
Don't worry about it.
Don't feel like you're like, oh, I have to have a pen light for...
If I go see Minto, I can't use a Hololive pen light.
No, no, no, no, no.
Go for it.
Don't worry about it.
I'm super happy to finally have some official merch and stuff to wear and represent you.
Thank you!
Is the Allies gonna make more of the Happy?
There were no plans to.
I did have people asking.
And we thought about extending the date, but...
If I do make more in the future, there'll probably be like a different design.
So don't think like those are the only Happy that will ever be released.
Really like how the Phantom Thief pen light has the colors in order.
Makes it easier to swap between you and Doki.
Really?
Let's go, Lumica.
Wait.
We're at 42,000, you guys.
We're killing it.
Make a Minto 3.0 Happy.
Stop.
Ruin it.
Stop guessing my plans.
Are lightsabers allowed?
Yeah, probably.
Just don't hit anybody in the head.
Just don't bonk it.
I wanna say something.
Ozzy!
It's going to be my birthday soon.
I'll sing you early happy birthday.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, Ozzy, Ozzy, Ozzy, Ozzy, Ozzy, Ozzy.
If you... So there's these things called UOs, if you're not sure what they are.
They're the pen lights that when you...
Not pen lights, sorry.
They're like glow sticks when you crack them.
They're super duper bright.
They're very popular in otage and people using them to like guruguru cyclone at concerts and things like that.
Idol lives and anisong lives and things like that.
If you break those...
When you throw them, it's called stardusting, actually.
Please do not do that.
It's so funny because I considered adding a song to my setlist.
It's called Yoake Brand New Days.
Which is the origin of Yet Tiger, actually.
At the end of the song, everybody throws their UOs up into the air.
But I thought it might be a little bit of a...
Of a niche song...
To have as in my setlist.
UOs are needed for Snow Halation.
Exactly, exactly.
But...
Yeah, I think that's like the only acceptable way of using...
Of throwing your UOs.
Otherwise, please don't throw them at people, at the screens, everything like that.
Like...
There's already been a couple tweets about it, but especially if you're throwing them...
At the screens or you accidentally hit somebody in the head and things like that.
Just don't throw them, please.
I know sometimes you're going crazy and you accidentally slip from your hand.
That's understandable, but...
You know, yeah.
Someone threw one during... Some people threw them several times during the concert, unfortunately.
So, yeah.
Kind of think of it as like how...
Like people throwing things at actual artists during concerts and stuff.
Like people will throw things at like Billie Eilish and, you know, things like that.
It's just like...
I don't know why this...
I know it's always been a thing, but I don't know why it's grown to be so much of a bigger thing recently.
But...
We love when everybody is yakai, but we don't love when things are damaged, you know?
So...
We love when you are yakai having fun.
But imagine if it had like, you know...
Hit the screen and caused like a little dead pixel area or something.
Then it would have ruined the experience for everyone.
Yakai responsibly.
Prune, welcome to Mabushu!
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Welcome, welcome!
Welcome, welcome, welcome.
Yeah, I just wanted to say that.
I just wanted to make sure I...
Put like a...
I guess a public statement out about that.
Especially because I, you know...
I feel that I...
How do I say?
I feel I am responsible a little bit.
Because it was my concert.
Hello, Mito-kun.
Hello!
Wahoo!
Old Snake!
Iceman!
Great profile picture.
No throwing lightsabers?
I don't even...
Would you even want to...
Would you even want to ruin your...
Like, potentially damage your lightsaber?
That would be so sad.
Mito invented Yakai.
Guys, we are at 53.
Wait, there is holocoin prizes?
1, 2, 3...
Wait.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6...
No!
It's so expensive!
What?
Maybe I do need the money.
Chris!
Welcome to bamboo ship!
Thank you!
Anip!
Thank you for the 50 gift!
Thank you!
Oh my gosh, thank you so much.
I can buy the drink.
A somewhat tasty drink.
This item does absolutely nothing.
It is an absolute scam.
You will only waste your chips from buying this.
But I can buy it.
Yeah, what if it's not a scam?
What if it's... What if they're just being, you know, a little playful about it?
They're like, it's definitely a scam!
I thought it would, like, say sold out.
But they allow you the option to even buy it again.
Look up?
What?
What did I do?
What's up?
That...
Yeah.
If you buy 1,000, you unlock Mew.
And then, you buy 1,000, then you look under the Pekora statue.
And that's where you'll find Mew.
Monkey!
Wait, I kinda want the beetle.
You need to play as Kanata and push the statue.
But Minky...
You're right.
Don't lose sight of the goal.
Okay, you're right.
You guys are right.
I'm gonna leave.
I'm gonna close out.
I'm gonna get out of here.
My workers are exhausted.
So is that a scam or a hustle?
I think we did good.
It was a flex of wealth.
It's like when somebody goes and gets the ice cream with the gold...
With the gold flakes on it, you know?
It doesn't taste any better.
It's just like...
I've had hot cocoa with gold flakes.
Not worth it.
I've had that.
I did feel fancy.
I bet.
I've never tried it before.
Anything with the gold flakes.
I've never had anything with the gold flakes.
Decreed us for...
Have some dignity, Chaz!
Please!
Can you do the Ojo-sama laugh?
Let me practice.
I don't think I can do it very well.
But I'll try.
I'll try.
I'm not the Ojo-sama.
I'm just a maid.
I'm not worthy.
Korone comes from the woods.
There she goes.
Away from the woods.
There she goes back into the woods.
Oh my gosh, there she is!
There's Mew behind the bush!
If you catch Korone...
Oh my gosh, that would be kind of crazy if there was like a secret thing where it's just like you talk to...
Oh, and there goes Mew.
You talk to somebody...
You talk to...
You talk to Kanata three times...
And spin around...
And then...
You talk to...
Then you...
When you...
Wait, no.
You then run to...
The tower.
Knock on the door three times.
And then you also...
You mine five...
Five diamond rocks.
And then you...
Unlock another...
Usada drink.
Can you say that again?
I missed it.
Write that down.
All that for water.
Hey, it's a doggy dog world out there.
Water's not free.
I thought a playable Yago.
No, that's too...
Someone's in this decay.
Free stuff.
This is my favorite part.
More free stuff.
Well guys, we did it.
Stage three, stage four.
I'm gonna change the title.
It says stage three hard, stage four hard...
Tutorial.
How to beat stage three, stage four.
First try.
Tutorial.
We're so good.
We're gamers, everybody.
Tutorial.
Walkthrough.
Fauna sweep.
Fauna sweep!
I'm so glad that last time I could use Kiwawa to get through the stages I wanted to.
And then this time I used Fauna to get through the stages I wanted to.
Using my Oshis...
Using my Oshis to beat the stages is the best feeling ever.
She makes it look easy.
One day kid...
One day kid, you can be on my level.
Can't wait till...
No, I don't want to be...
No, I don't...
You know...
I feel bad when people are just like...
Win...
You know, indie...
Friend DLC or win friend DLC and stuff like that, but...
I don't know, I feel like it's adding too much pressure to...
You know, it's holo cure, everybody.
It's holo cure.
I'm perfectly fine with it remaining that way.
So...
Don't worry about it.
Walk through, pick Fauna, exactly.
Holo is holo, exactly.
And I very much love being a fan of hololive.
Dope.
Yeah!
Congrats on the successful concert, Minto!
Thanks, Nami!
Hope you get plenty of rest when you can.
Thank you!
She hates K.U.
Yeah, I hate that guy!
It's okay.
The feeling is mutual.
It's a... It's a hate-hate.
You know?
Can't wait for Furumako.
I know!
I can't wait.
But now there's...
Advent and Justice that they have to add.
So... And all the other JPs.
Too much... Too many women.
Can you tell us how to unlock holo from spice and move in the game?
You talk to Kanata three times.
Remember?
One... Oh, I'm fishing.
Get me out of here!
I don't want to fish!
Talk...
What?
What?!
What did I just catch?
How do I have ten axolotls?
What did I just get?
But
I've gotten the turtle before!
The golden koi is from before.
It wasn't the golden koi.
I got that off stream, actually.
Sorry.
I'm... I... I
think it must have been an axolotl.
Or something, because...
I've never actually caught an axolotl on my...
On my...
In here.
I've only gotten it through the stages.
I'm so...
Check the tapes later.
Yeah, I have to watch the VOD.
Which means, I have to go!
Thank you guys!
What a crazy way to end the stream!
I... My mind is blown right now!
I've been trying to get that achievement for so long!
And I just got it!
On a one-off chance!
I am... I am absolutely...
I can't believe it!
I absolutely...
Thank you so much, you guys, for the stream!
Say Kanata three times!
Talk to Kanata three times, everybody!
It works!
Every time!
Otsuminto!
Have a great rest of your day or your night!
And I'll see you guys next time!
Thank you guys!
Bye-bye!